whoa what happened there
okay let's go from the top so Magnus
with white against nielskarandalius
yeah another another occurrence of uh of
ah that position again
this is just a position of the
tournament somehow everybody's playing
it there's there's a rash there's a rash
of this variation
and yeah Asics uh we have seen shark
play which would be 796 but we also seen
this oh and he just missed I mean missed
maybe is wrong but he allowed the 5v4
and now after after year three
which Buffet Knight C3 is probably what
he missed yeah
you have to assume this is what he
missed
and unlikely to an fg2 is a very cute
little we're gonna put it on the board
there we go absolutely yeah
so he had to go back to B2 and play fg2
rookie one
uh but honestly the position I
understand that this is probably not
ideal
but it doesn't look clear at all because
the pollen G2
actually works as a pretty decent shield
for the white king and black doesn't
actually have a Pawn on G7 so you can
imagine the bishop on B2 playing a very
major role
uh in in the rest of this game although
I guess eventually you can play F7 F6
and uh
blunt it a little bit actually very
interesting developments there so we
left it but we can't we take on before
twice
let's have a look this is where we've
got to Queen to seven is unbelievable
because Queen before
I thought Rook C7 was made
and it is indeed made just not to the
side that I thought it was
okay fair enough and without that Bishop
our attack is really not that great so
take care Queen G7 is actually made
right I'm sorry yeah that's that that no
longer works yeah that no longer works
rookies haven't played by Magnus so
what's the bailout for Nils if he wants
a bailout here might see two maybe well
okay so how did how do we get he blood
Queen he's six
just to land the Knight on E5 and now
after Queen takes before we can give a
check and then a check from G4 and then
play Queen H3 hang on what ah there's
line G3 there I'm I'm once again being
willfully stupid if you give a check
King G2
you can play Knight takes C1
that is a legitimate movie you can try
but Queen g493 was on the spot I'm
pretty sure
here white will have to play King F1 I
suspect and we can try putting the
Knight on some good Square 93 Queen try
this one or queen
yeah I don't know which Square to choose
um
Queen E7 maybe even
that doesn't look quite right when you
saw the bad move but like I don't know
if it's the best but we need seven takes
takes with the bishop I do win the F6
bonus check it's not horrible but there
might be something stronger blood got
mated
95 here so he's gone for this eye the
king went to G3 which is even smarter I
guess too
to stop all the check is going to five
for four
and uh yeah Queen's Queen C4 Queen City
Amish buffet and then Queen C7 very very
facile
uh Victory from a certain point onwards
by Magnus I still have to wonder if uh
this kind of a
uh all in with queen e695 was necessary
didn't really feel like
uh Niels absolutely had to go for that
but